because political correctness grew for a
lot longer than a lot of people think it
did people came up became aware of it in
the 80s and 90s
really it predates it it was a very
intentional sort of strategy
and one of the aspects of this that
occurred really in the 70s through the
radical feminists was to politicize
everything that the personal had to
become the political the most intimate
sort of choices and interactions had to
become political political choices so
now you know you can buy the
conservative running shoes or the
liberal running shoes you can buy the
conservative coffee
or the liberal coffee this is true now
of pillows
so you know there's mike lindell who has
advertised on this show
before uh who makes a fabulous product
my pillow
is advertised on a lot of conservative
networks he has my pillow now david hogg
who became a sort of celebrity after the
parkland shooting
and he formed all these various groups
and stumped for a lot of candidates and
you know made made himself a sort of a
sensation
he's founding a rival pillow company now
there's some question as to whether or
not they're actually going to do the
pillow company
because they say oh yes we're going to
start this pillow company he's he's
teamed up with an internet troll
whose name i think is william legate or
legate
um and uh so i don't know if it's real
or if it's just kind of a publicity
stunt
they were asking you know basically how
to do it how do you make a pillow
company so i don't know that it's really
gonna happen but even the idea that this
is a story
shows you something about the state of
our culture so you have my pillow
on the right and some people are calling
david hogg's company
mao pillow on the left uh it's not a bad
idea
you might have some copyright issues in
china but china doesn't care about
copyrights anyway so
you know go for it uh
how much further does that go well this
will this affect every single
product will the quality of the product
matter you know mike lindell he's not
paying me to say this right now right he
didn't buy any ads on the show today
the man makes a great pillow because say
what you will you might hate his
politics
the man makes a magnificent pillow will
mr hogg make a good pillow i don't know
maybe will it matter
i don't know i don't know that it will
or will people's affinity for these
political issues
overcome it you know mike lindell
uh you know sort of he's an eccentric
character in public life he's always
made himself out to be he goes on the
commercials he goes on media a lot
but when when that coronavirus really
kicked up earlier in 2020
mike lindell went in he said i'm
converting some factories from making
sheets and pillowcases
i'm going to make masks and i have some
of mike lindell's masks and they're
excellent masks they're the most
breathable comfortable masks that i have
i don't even know if he sold them i
think he may have just donated them or
something
that was a long time ago that was back
in march and
april in may and june we're told okay
you know the masks you've got to wear
them but it's only
15 days to slow the spread now we're
coming up on a year
of this if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
[Music]